like a sport that you've never done that
you want to try uh
speed ice skating looks so cool the
racing there was um
that's that's this seems so dangerous i
thought about that because there was uh
somebody watching
reached out to me on twitter and i was
like because they were verified they're
like 1 000 followers
and they were they were on like yeah
they were a pro ice skater in like
america canada yeah yeah i love trash
taste and they were on the olympic team
oh wow
wow like ice skating and they watch it
so i think i think ice skating's real
cool
real cool teach me no i love ice skating
i'd love to like go fast and do it but i
mean yeah that's too dangerous
i'll slam my face i'd have to like get
past that mental barrier of just like
you know you know when you reach a
certain speed and
especially if you're not used to it you
have to get past that barrier i've just
like i'm going a bit
too fast now if i fall it's really gonna
hurt
i want you know what olympic sport i
want to exist but will never exist is
like you know the
when you go to like round one here and
you get the zorb ball
it's like football where you're wearing
like this is the balls where you can
run into each other that'd be such a fun
olympic sport
people on the field [ __ ] just [ __ ]
crashing
like if you ever come to japan come to
round one because most round one
have this you're gonna see you're gonna
see another sports show it's called
yeah yeah yeah so you're gonna see it on
screen now this is this you can easily
get access to this
um yeah they're everywhere and then a
lot of round ones in japan yeah they're
like
bb gun shooting yeah yeah it's
surprisingly because
we i remember when we did it right in
the [ __ ] summer which was a
[ __ ] stupid move right right after we
had like the biggest ball
curry so we were like we were in the
[ __ ] zorb balls just like rolling
around which is like
oh i'm go i'm going to throw up it's
surprisingly
uh it was we should go back there we
haven't been there in so long yeah
it was surprisingly [ __ ] tiring to do
that though oh yeah yeah like it looks
it looks really
light to just run around no it's not it
is
it is kind of like playing a mario party
game right
because like it feels like you're
because you're playing football but it's
got this like really janky physics
engine
it's like trying to drive a car and like
cyber funk or something like that custom
game mode
like big head modes where you're just
[ __ ] top heads
literally gang beast control
fun as [ __ ] i'd love that to be a sport
are you guys going to go watch any of
the olympic sports if it happens
the [ __ ] do i apply no well no
supposedly now that like i think it's
been confirmed that
they're not going to bring any
foreigners in right so but you can go
see it at the stadium which means
there's going to be
way more available seats for the actual
olympics i kind of want to do it just
because like
do you know how to get tickets i'm going
to look into it i have no idea because
like if i can find it out
then i'd want to go just to say i've
been right yeah the only time i've ever
seen tickets available the only way you
could win it was by buying something
from panasonic and you get entered into
a lottery
yeah which which of maybe you'll get the
right to buy it yeah that's that sounds
like a very japanese
japanese thing to do i don't want to buy
panasonic i want
a ticket to the olympics because this
would be the
second time that i've lived in a city
where the olympics is held
because i was there for london you went
there in london i was in
wales at that time oh yeah so i was yeah
i was living in london at the time and
uh
yeah i i mean i when
during the normal olympics things just
like get super super busy
and i don't really like crowds that much
anyway
so go like i didn't want to go through
the hassle of going through it to a
sporting event and
i don't know i i didn't care enough
about the sport
for me to want to go to this big
sporting event where i you know i just
i literally just said the olympics is
where you watch sports you normally
don't care about but right
you watch it because it's the olympics
right um so i don't even know what sport
i would want to watch
like i don't know would you just want to
watch any sport
if you watch a sport but it's like a bad
game like it's a bad matchup yeah it's
like a stomp it'll be like america
versus like
venezuela or basketball
no i feel like i don't know with those
kinds of stuff i feel it's just you go
to just
enjoy the atmosphere you know because
like i remember have you been
i've never been to the olympics but how
would you know that feels good well
because
well i mean every other sporting event
i've been to
because like i remember i went to go
watch uh like but like japanese
atmosphere though in a crowd
they're not very rowdy are they yeah
that's not true i went to go see the
baseball here and it was
really really fun i mean it was a [ __ ]
game really what was fun about it
i i i say this having been to a baseball
game in the us
and uh i kind of found it a bit boring
oh really oh okay
you don't love the kiss cam gone what
what
i feel okay okay this might be a bit
biased because i i actually quite
enjoy watching the baseball everything
but i also don't enjoy cricket either
no i'm just making i'm just making an
enemy of like the us
australia india now who who else wanted
to do all the sports
they all suck well because like i
remember i went to go watch a rugby game
and it's like i'm not huge into the
rugby but
watching rugby games is fun though yeah
on the tv yeah oh yeah in person
yeah oh yeah well i'm like i would get
inside i win i went watch the rugby and
it's like it was a [ __ ] game because our
team got [ __ ] destroyed but i still
had a really fun time just because of
the atmosphere yeah everyone's rounding
the crowd
yeah yeah yeah but the baseball baseball
was the same thing as well like my team
was losing but i didn't really give a
[ __ ] because it was just
i don't know it's just fun yeah because
like how how we had fun was just getting
very very drunk in milwaukee
and like everyone was just very drunk
and it was just like i don't know what
the [ __ ] going on i'm having a good
i'm having a good time now though
because i'm pretty drunk
another milliliter i was like yes i'll
pay for another eight dollar
hot dog hot dog that is not me i'll have
that yeah i don't know i just
i just like having an active component
to my sport i guess i i
i i how can i say this i don't like when
sports are stop starts
you know i i i like it to be like so
you're not into like the nfl
or anything like that oh my god bro
watching nfl is hard
the amount of ads they have yeah but
it's also very stop start heavy game
right but
like i feel like the nfl is like i can
get into the end of nfl because
when the game is in motion that i i've
like it's hard to find a sport
as exciting as the nfl when everything
is in motion right
winning over our american audience
like because there's so there's so many
things going on in such a
short period of time whereas you know i
look at something like cricket
or baseball and there's only you know
there's yeah it's very stop stop
it's very stop start and there's there's
you know there's i'm gonna sound like so
i'm sorry i'm sounds so bad it's just i
just see like a guy trying to hit a ball
you know